so I don't know about you but I want to
commit burgle bezel meant that I was at
Berger puzzlement whatever it was
amazing and it was a crime he invented
himself so props to that has a new crime
he invent along with teaching bears how
to drive I want to say that was from a
past episode I'm sure it was yeah monie
hearing it again so yeah this is the
stand
Jerry candidate Stan tries to run for
mayor and little Gideon's father tries
to under the control little Gideon and
it's me it's my fights its Muffy and
then the get'em guy who I thought we
heard his name but I did I just so
called the get him guy I was saying to
would it be great if he became there I
need and I'm actually kind of happy for
and but Stan is obviously kind of Donald
Trump of what he's doing so
dipper hey hey hey man let's be honest
he's way more charismatic than Donald
Trump never be actually and yeah so he
also more of a humanitarian yeah
honestly got stan is such a better
candidate than though Trump potentially
I would I would vote for Stanley hands
down yes Lee God
it's like he sounds amazing now compared
to Donald Trump I mean it's like wow oh
but I'm sorry we're really getting in
there but so they try the control really
Gideon has the trumpet air that is true
I mean that is totally get Gideon's hair
is totally Trump hair or let's let's be
honest hair I'll infuse the two together
let's be honest the big thing at the end
is Gideon revealing days ready to make a
deal with holy shit is just like shit
and they usually during the credits is
usually like just before the credits
something like
okay whatever here's your will throw a
joke whatever it's just like gonna fuck
no that was really nice yeah I thought
was this something they were just gonna
toss at us for a joke and I was like oh
shit so that was nice to see you nice to
see he'll be coming back yeah cuz we
kind of knew like after the big reveal
of Stan's brother say okay now we're
gonna get a couple you know for a like a
bear where we say filler episodes but
there was a reintroduction to Gideon
again yeah the fact that giddy the the
when Gideon's dad showed up I already
knew like okay we're gonna go somewhere
with this because I was like you're not
gonna bring them back I am going to jail
yeah so yeah but yeah I mean it's fun I
don't like it as much as the last one
the dungeons dungeons and more dungeons
that one was brilliant this one's just
good yeah like this one's good I think
there's something about every every time
election season comes around like we we
all get pissed off we all get aggravated
we all hate these political ads we all
hate them demonizing the RSI and making
the other look right
I agree Roseanne Barr the only time they
tell the truth is one they call each
other wires and we just all get really
really frustrated so when we see
something like that's mocking that it's
like I think we kind of want to like its
awakening our frustration but at the
same time it's been done so much that
even when it's done well it's kind of
like okay I kind of know these tricks
but some of them were really creative I
think throwing the birdseed and seeing
which one the eagle does it all the $20
range honestly I think we should just do
that but the candidates out there right
now I'm just like you know and I would I
would let the Eagle choose yeah but it
can't be worse in the system we have now
when you look at the people running the
clown car of people running guns is like
yeah something something's out right
but the somewhere we mess down yeah but
our complete disillusion of a nation
aside yeah no I
I kind of agree like I feel like these
jokes have been done before I fade I
feel like the ultimate one was always
Simpsons with the Bob Dole Clinton
episode the Halloween special
I always thought that one nailed
elections so well that I always felt
like I've just been watching kind of a
repeat of that episode anytime someone
else does it then this was funny I
thought they were very clever some
things they did but I kind of felt the
same here I'm like yeah it's not saying
anything different that that Simpsons
way back in 96 didn't say yeah I think
it's saying where they probably think to
themselves you know Stan running for
mayor like what would that be like
that'd be really funny is funny it's
just not like you know I do like the
things he says I can put the kids on an
island let them fight to the death
yeah anything making it look more like a
criminal is always great but yeah I
think it's it's good it's funny it's not
quite I feel like Betsy the old-timey
mayor apparently may have started World
War one yeah Mary said may have also
started the first world war thing what
else yeah I mean it was funny it was
fine it was I had some good jokes and
everything and some fun satire but yeah
I mean it's I I get it that I think the
creators needed to vent a bit like in
this election season of all I feel like
it's very necessary to get that off your
chest the office um yeah but I think
it's one of those things where it's like
you know and on top of that like looks
like the next episode it's probably
gonna be a big one with you know Gideon
coming back and Seifer coming back and
stuff so it's one of those things where
it's like oh really there's other
episodes are gonna be plenty more but
the phone interview I love because
particularly when well when dipper made
were talked about like he's speaking his
mind oh and we really are in trouble and
then the phony just cut the line I was
like you just know there's like somebody
out there like it on a PR team that just
so wants to do that right now and spec
if I just had the scissors just snip but
uh yeah it was good it was funny it was
nothing phenomenal I don't think it's
meant to be anything phenomenal I don't
think it's meant to be like one of these
it gets it gets us to the point that now
we know Guineans gonna cut a deal and
that that I think was the most important
thing yeah I think I'll reintroduced him
a bit as okay
Victor and the father as well you know
ya can't forget him to the Father that
isn't the mother can that the money am I
using a 30% off we are you and you and
you
we're from Chicago so Oprah humor flies
here pretty yeah we um I do like feet I
get a feeling we're gonna see more of
tad strange because that guy was so
weird but it was just like no no it's
like your mom I think you guys like
bread even wait didn't say anything
funny it was just so distinct and so
like you know yes I'm I'm confident in
my thing yeah it was just like yeah
you're funny I like you
so um yeah good stuff can't think of too
much else and uh that's about it and
we'll see you in the next five weeks
when the next one comes out for whatever
comes out so yeah well we'll just see ya
then later boo grunkle Stan